all right let's turn to our series the
dish which today serves up some Texas
barbecue with an international twist
that is both unexpected and delicious
the Arlington Texas restaurant called
Smoke and Ash was the brainchild of a
married couple who combined the food of
their childhoods to create a recipe for
Success Jamie wax got the sample the
menu and he joins us now to talk about
it Jamie sounds delicious good morning
it was delicious Vlad good morning you
might not think Ethiopian and Texan
Cuisine would mix but when fasika and
Patrick Hicks combine their recipes they
created an international sensation both
Cuisines start with smoke the Common
Thread at smoke and Ash and in with full
happy stomachs and a lot of used napkins
so we're going from Texas to Ethiopia to
St Louis with this planet oh yeah I love
it this is global barbecue here
sometimes the most unexpected
combinations
from the most unexpected places make the
most surprising culinary Delights look
at the cap of melted fat on that that is
just gorgeous that is beautiful like
it's smoke and Ash this unassuming
restaurant in a small Strip Mall in
Arlington Texas has all you'd expect in
a barbecue place like ribs and brisket
I'm going to steal a rib tip from from
your beautiful platter all right
boy is perfect just tender and Smoky and
you haven't even finished it yet but the
secret sauce brings an international
Flair with spice rubs and sauces from
Ethiopia I have the Burberry sauce which
is we call it awaze and this blend of
Southwest U.S and East Africa is
deliciously unique now I can see why
your customers are so loyal because they
literally can't get this anywhere not
nowhere else nowhere else Patrick Hicks
is a born and bred Texan from Waco his
wife asika Hicks is from Addis Ababa the
kettle of Ethiopia they met in 1997
after she immigrated to Texas Thursday
was it at IHOP in um I wanted like the
chicken fried steak with eggs pancakes
this was about food from the very oh
yeah yes yes both of them like to cook
and Patrick's barbecue became a favorite
of fasika's Ethiopian family seeing her
family's Delight gave her an idea I was
telling him hey you know way we can make
money selling this food so we bought a
trailer and make some extra money on a
weekend before we know it we start
forming lines because people look
forward to our cooking every weekend and
then that blossomed into to this place
yes but this was still traditional Texas
barbecue that's right yeah and in 2019
you had a great inspiration yes I got
bored with his cooking so I was telling
him hey why don't I make an Ethiopian
food and sell it on the side it wasn't
long before that Ethiopian food on the
side became part of the main menu and
the Hicks can thank their customers for
that I had customers who come in for
example for the vegan combo we have and
they come to tell us on the register hey
can I add the half pound of brisket to
go with it can you put them on the same
plate only in Texas did someone ordered
the vegan combo with a cider brisket so
I was just saying okay always take care
of your customers because I was kind of
hesitant
with diners enjoying the two tastes
together the couple decided just having
the meal share the same plate wasn't
enough
mix it up together why not have the
flavors combined in the same recipe to
guarantee the authenticity fasika's
sister gathers Ethiopian spices in Addis
Ababa and ships them to Texas and the
result is perhaps the only Ethiopian
Texas Barbecue on the planet and here's
your set loss cut pork ribs smoked with
barbare the signature dish at smoke and
Ash the Tex Ethiopian platter naturally
we have smoked ribs collard green
featuring American barbecue Staples from
brisket to catfish to Texas toast as
well as Ethiopian dishes like chicken
Dora what we have some tortillas or we
call it Gita in Ethiopia and the
barbecue sauce which is spiced with as
well there's another secret ingredient
behind the success of smoke and Ash and
it's not uniquely Ethiopian or Texan
when it comes to food for me it's just
about togetherness you work one of those
love and care and you make it to be the
best thing on a plate
and smoking Ash is doing so well they're
actually looking for a bigger place I
think they'll be even busier after
people see this it's it's worth a trip
to Arlington it really is when I was a
foreign correspondent based in Africa
that's when I came to realize that a lot
of the foods that we eat especially the
foods that are made down south have a
direct influence from what happened on
the continent obviously through the
transatlantic slave trade but it is
there is a way to marry those flavors
today makes complete sense to me love
the red trays and the styrofoam cups too
it is it is a genuine Gem of a place and
there's nothing gimmicky about this food
it's very thoughtful some of the most
delicious food I've ever eaten makes me
want to go Jamie I do I do eat a lot I
could drive in the HOV lane in Texas my
food baby I had after
you pregnant I want that interview